on day one of my new Administration I
will direct the doj to investigate every
radical D.A and attorney general in
America for their radical according to
whom illegal racist and reverse
enforcement of the law a genuinely
deranged and dangerous idea and
understand that Trump wants if Trump had
his way
he would get rid of any federal
government employee that simply didn't
vote for him even if they are
non-political Trump that this is one of
Trump's big big Crusades he wants to be
able to fire everyone and replace them
with loyalists even in bureaucratic
positions where politics really
shouldn't make a difference and he wants
to do the same thing with DA's and
Attorneys General not going to happen by
the way just completely absurd but it's
not going to happen